breaking overnight teachers and school
officials in los angeles have a deal to
reopen america's second largest public
school district
students have been out of classrooms
there for nearly a year because of the
coronavirus and some parents are
pursuing a class action lawsuit against
the school district and teachers union
carr evans is in los angeles for us this
morning carter good morning to you
good morning tony teachers still have to
vote to approve this deal but if it
passes
school staff will still have weeks to
get vaccinated before heading back
elementary students will return mid
april everyone else by the end of april
but some la parents say it's too late
after a year attempting distance
learning
the damage is done
for students like eleven-year-old makai
allen it'll be another
six weeks before he could be back in the
classroom this school year
was a major problem he's one of more
than
650 thousand l.a public school students
who've been trying to learn online for
nearly a year now
is makai getting a quality education
right now
no he's not getting what he deserves
makai's mother kishar shah says he
sometimes has less than two hours of
teacher instruction a day
to him it feels like no one cares it
feels like if
they're giving me the minimum to do his
effort has become the minimum
now she's part of a class action lawsuit
against the school district and the
teachers union
which claims students are losing 17 to
19 and a half hours of instructional
time every week
in a district where nearly 80 percent of
the students
qualified for free or reduced price
meals the lawsuit says the number of
weekly hours of live instruction is less
than
half what it was before the pandemic
why is that i don't agree with that
cecily meyer cruz is president of the la
teachers union we spoke to her before
the tentative agreement
things are not going to be perfect but
many of our
educators are giving of themselves
daily to this crisis distance learning
cdc and state guidelines allow for
elementary schools to open
now for nearly a month the teachers
union had been fighting for stricter
measures
they said all along all three paces
health standard in schools
lower coveted in the community and
vaccinations for school staff
l.a superintendent austin buettner
showed us a school vaccination site
you ready where teachers and staff can
now get a shot
he says the district has spent more than
a billion dollars since the pandemic
started
part of that on upgrading campus air
filtration systems
stocking schools with protective
equipment and testing staff and students
would you say what is going on now as
far as education in los
angeles would you call that a success
absolutely
absolutely we're doing the best we can
in the safest way we can this is
definitely not enough
so a success for who i'm not sure
not my child well the lawsuit is still
moving forward the families involved
want the school district to be held
accountable
for the harm they say the educational
program is cost now when schools finally
do reopen
it's going to look very different
classes will be dramatically smaller
with students alternating between online
and
in-person instruction and gail i should
point out that i have two children
in public school here in los angeles in
elementary school
and they're really excited to get back
to class and i'll bet
dad and mom are excited to get back to
class too yes that's great thank you
very much carter